two uninhabited Pacific Islands more than 5,000 miles from the UK one will be inhabited by 14
British men while a separate island will be home to 14 British women for six weeks they'll
be utterly alone with only the clothes they stand up in and a handful of basic tools filming
everything themselves when pushed to the limits of human endurance will it be brute power or mental
strength the winds of day who will have what it takes to stay alive tonight we follow the
women's island this time it'll be harder than ever
hunt for food find water and build shelter living on the island in the middle of tropical storm
season when pitted against the extremes of nature and these Monday women got what it takes to survive
four days ago 14 British women were cast away on this remote uninhabited Pacific Island
already one woman has left the island I need to go
who's up for this
some of the group stayed behind at the makeshift camp whilst an expedition party went in search of
a permanent base with a sustainable water source it's not salty but with no idea how to get back
to the others they are now lost in the thick of the jungle and are completely out of water
we have nothing to drink we don't know where we are
the women left behind have just rain water to drink their fire has gone out and panic is setting in
with both groups now starving and critically dehydrated their time on the island could be
over before it's really begun it's day four
the five women left in camp have been waiting for over 24 hours for the others to return from their
expedition
I feel dreadful honestly I feel absolutely dreadful I never thought I would be so desperate
for food and water we all want to get out of this camp but we know the other group are coming back
for us we can't set off because we'll lose them the women are trying to relight their fire to
purify water from a muddy puddle but their wood is damp
that's it
next it's moving oh every time what the hell are we doing there's actually just another
Groundhog Day of the same it's like the best camping ever isn't it the best camping
every time camping twice I don't like it
however bad your situation is you have to dig deep and find that inner strength to stand any chance of surviving the adapted nature of magn Tookhealth tours are nowScreenreviews.com
for more Sammy Laimo and the family you love we'll see you this weekend
now you can view what comes next next portion in the Descent of the Ocean
video How you'll get started until you hit the video这 куда就不 racket
you'll get started until you hit the video this one walk
surviving. You know, simple principles that really make a big difference, and one of those
is positivity, positivity, positivity.
I might as well, honestly, I might as well have gone and sat in my horse's field for
five days and not eaten, but just sat in the muddiest part of the horse's field, but the
difference is I might have had a horse for company.
I don't actually mind, because I love extremes of weather. I like roaring wind and lightning
and torrential rain and...
Oh, lovely. I'm pleased for you. Seriously, I'm really chuffed for you.
I've always wanted an adventure, and I thank God I haven't done that much for myself over
the last 55 years. Should have done more. Should have seen more.
I get really wound up over the most stupid things. Like, you know when you buy expensive
toilet roll and then you tear it and it doesn't tear along the perforations? That really winds
me up.
I try to stop myself talking a lot, but I do like to think that other people can get
away with it in edgeways, you know what I mean?
This is day four now without any food, so we're really going to feel it today.
Earlier, the women found some yucca, a type of potato. Mother of two, Julie, has decided
to peel it, despite not having a fire to cook it on.
Oh, now, do you know what? I've just wasted that now.
But we could have boiled it in soup, that's what Beth was saying.
I would please leave the yucca.
If she goes on about those potatoes anymore, I'm going to stab her.
After 24 hours without a drink, the expedition party are dehydrated, hopelessly lost, and
wandering directionless.
Walking is painful now, physically and mentally.
I just hope we can find a drink.
I can't remember the time I felt this thirsty.
Careful here, guys, it's really slippery.
Oh, shit.
Are you all right?
Super slippery.
Really slippery.
Oh, God.
Oh, .
Hey.
Who was that?
That was me.
Oh, my God, there's a caiman.
That is a big .
Oh, yes, I can see it.
Straight ahead.
Oh, shit.
Oh, my God, that's .
Yeah, it's enormous.
It's watching us, though.
We actually, I just can't, I literally must have walked past his nose by that much.
Didn't spot him.
Did we throw things at his hip?
No.
Though potentially deadly to humans, a crocodile of this size is the most likely
to die.
Oh, my God.
Though potentially deadly to humans, a crocodile of this size could provide tens of thousands
of calories for the women who have barely eaten in days.
Billy Big Balls, that.
That is a serious Billy Big Ball.
I'm not going for that one for dinner, then.
Not tonight, not without a fire.
We wouldn't tackle that unless we don't have a sharp knife on us.
We'll be back for you, men.
Sleep with one eye open.
With hunger and dehydration sapping their energy and with hunting equipment left at camp,
the women decide to walk away from this potentially deadly crocodile.
A life-saving feast.
Right, let's get out of here.
Nothing easy on this.
Hey, it's all right.
It's all right.
That's it.
Well done.
As we know, caiman can take off a leg, an arm, drag you into the water, drown you,
eat you.
Not great, really.
So we all want to be out of here as fast as possible.
And as an exit operation, we're doing quite well.
Oh, darn you, dear.
Yeah.
Too late.
Too late, baby.
It's too late.
For these women to succeed they've got to have faith.
They've got to persevere and reunite because there's power in numbers.
My mantra is lead no man behind.
It's that sort of attitude that's going to make the critical difference for them.
I've got a beach on my left.
Oh, no.
Let's get on that.
Let's get an orientation.
The women have been trekking through the jungle for two hours,
but instead of finding camp,
they've stumbled upon another beach on the north of the island.
This is so hard.
No-one knows what the right decision is.
It's so thirsty.
I've never been so dehydrated in all my life.
I'm thinking about drinking seawater.
I know you can't, but I'm not...
The women scavenge the area and strike lucky.
We found coconut!
Oh, my God!
It's just enough to keep them going.
Come on, let's go, let's go. Let's do it.
As they head back into the jungle to try and find the others once more.
At camp, the damp conditions are proving problematic.
I really...
I was, of course, trying to say,
let's start another fire.
It's finding the dry stuff.
There's no sun. We can't see the sky.
Oh, but look at your little hands.
My hands. I'm like...
Can you see?
Like, look.
It's just from the wetness.
They're going to crack.
I'm in agony.
I've achieved everything I wanted to in my profession.
I'm really happy with where I've got to,
but I think my job is starting to define me,
and I don't want that.
I want to find out who I am again.
I think I have a need for adventure.
I just feel so driven to do something completely different.
It's crazy.
I can't let it get in my head.
You can't let it get in your head.
No.
It's important to be positive.
Right.
It will work out. It will.
We're about to work out how to make a great shelter today.
Unable to make fire without dry wood,
a shelter will protect the women from the elements
while they wait for the others to come back for them.
Push it down. Push that down.
No. No, this, the top one. Push that down.
I'll tell you what, there really is strength in numbers.
You really feel that there's so much more work
and so much more pressure on you
when there's just a small amount of you.
Oh, shit. That's it. There we go.
Now, with just five of us, it feels pretty lonely, actually.
Half an hour later,
and the shape of a shelter is almost complete.
It looks pretty good.
Oh, for fuck's sake.
Positivity, positivity, positivity.
The expedition party left what they've nicknamed Coconut Beach
nearly two hours ago,
and they are trekking into the thick of the jungle,
trying to find a camp.
No, we're going back on ourselves. We need to go that way.
There's the other coast beach.
With the afternoon temperature rising to over 30 degrees...
I'm so thirsty.
..their need for water is more critical than ever.
My biggest motivation is to get to the others.
Convinced they're close to camp,
Georgie and Lauren go ahead to recce their surroundings.
We're just looking.
They're not going anywhere.
We're going back to where we are.
We're back to where we are.
No fucking way.
Can't be.
We are?
No, we can't be.
We haven't done one massive se...
Yeah.
Really?
The expedition party have spent all day in the searing heat,
only to find they've walked in one big circle,
back to Coconut Beach.
in one big circle, back to Coconut Beach.
Guys, do you want to come down?
OK.
Without a GPS or visual landmarks to guide us,
human beings are naturally prone to walk in circles,
even when we're convinced we're going in a straight line.
Put dehydration into the mix, which slows down brain function
and the women find themselves in crisis.
OK, so there's some bad, bad news.
We're back where we were.
If the women don't find a proper water source soon,
their time on the island will end.
Bad news is we fucked up and we've just done a massive circle
and we've wasted a load of energy for nothing.
How the fuck did that happen?
All too easily.
We're in the jungle.
Got no fucking reference point.
And we're tired and dehydrated.
I vote we bed in for the night.
I think I'm going to cry, George.
I think I'm going to cry, don't you?
This is absolutely fucking ludicrous.
Physically, I don't know, people have got holes in their feet.
I have now.
We can't sustain this.
Oh, my God, what are we going to do back at the camp?
Four days ago, I abandoned a group of ordinary British women
on a remote, uninhabited Pacific island.
After separating over 24 hours ago,
the expedition party are desperately trying to get back to camp.
But disorientated by the jungle,
they remain in the north of the island.
The women left waiting at camp have no fire to purify water
and are also worryingly dehydrated.
We've been drinking water from a roof by wild animals.
Mum of two, Julie, has been down at the rocks
washing the women's muddy underwear.
There's only five of us here at the moment.
The other group have got lost.
We've no idea where they are.
A couple of our groupers are just moaning all the time.
I mean, for God's sake, it's supposed to be survival.
It's not supposed to be a holiday.
You know what I mean? We knew it was going to be tough.
Facing a second night isolated from the others...
What the fuck?
..the claustrophobic jungle environment
is testing the women's mental strength.
But it's been very difficult to stay positive.
I don't feel we've got anything.
I don't have anything to look forward to.
I just feel like we've been dumped.
Can I say something positive?
No, fuck off.
I don't feel too bad, you know?
And I just think it can only get better.
To be fair, Julie, you really haven't gone on any expeditions to get anything.
You've kind of conserved the energy by staying in camp the most of the time.
You are good at talking the talk, let's do this, let's do that,
but actually actively doing it is a different story.
Maybe that's why you're feeling so good.
I appreciate it.
Everybody is really fucking pissed off.
All I said was a bit of positivity.
I've spent fucking hours rearranging wet knickers
and washing all around this camp.
I don't want you to do that, Julie!
And squeezing it out and hanging it up for you.
I've been biting my tongue all the time.
You don't want me to do it?
Personally, I feel that constantly wringing out people's knickers
that aren't even here in other clothes is futile.
The group dynamics of these five people is not working.
Yeah.
It's not productive.
And I'm sat here thinking, I am stuck with this.
But we collected it at night as well, Julie, but you just walked with us.
How the fuck do you keep a fire going then?
You're not listening to me, are you?
Do you know what? I'm not, you're right.
What I'm saying is, we should collect wood and...
So, I'm doing the selfie now,
because you really need to know how I'm feeling.
It's really hard.
I just can't get enough of the photoshoots.
We can't eat.
Because we have no fire.
I don't know where everyone else is, the other group have gone missing and I'm really worried
about them, but I'm just questioning how on earth are we expected to survive in this?
On Coconut Beach in the north of the island, the expedition party remain out of water and
have decided to stay the night.
They're building a makeshift shelter.
We've basically spent two days walking for four and a half hours, that's nine hours in
total we've spent walking around this bloody island trying to get back to where we started.
Everybody's very dehydrated.
We've not had actual water for two days, it's just, it's ridiculous.
It's absolutely ridiculous.
And then the other side would go like that?
Yeah, brilliant.
After spotting a storm on the horizon, the women scavenge the beach for containers to
collect rainwater, their only hope of rehydrating.
We're going to have to support the bottles and this polystyrene thing so that they're
upright and they don't spill.
And we may have to keep it behind the slug so that the tide doesn't wash it out.
Finding fresh water is so important.
That combination of very oppressive 30 degree heat plus the humidity, you know, over 90%
of the time, it can easily mean the women get through a litre of water an hour.
That is a lot.
Unless they find water, I reckon the women only have one more day.
As night draws in, the women abandoned at camp are attempting to light a new fire to
purify their muddy rainwater.
Remember, all we're doing now is trying to make a hole.
It's out, it's out.
Oh, fuck's sake.
It's out.
All day, Julie's been at me, non-stop.
I've come on this experience to try new things,
to push my comfort zones.
Hello?
Guys?
Can someone shine their light over here?
Cos I swear I'm hearing noises.
Please, it's like a...
Is someone moving?
It's coming close to me, please!
It's Julie!
Oh, fuck my life.
Oh, shit.
On Coconut Beach, the storm is still in the distance,
and the dehydrated women are pinning all their hopes
on their makeshift containers collecting rain.
I've never actually wanted water so much in my life.
Check this lightning out behind me.
Yes!
It's so cool.
I don't know if you can actually see the line of lightning.
Look, I feel like a weather girl.
I'm not sure if you can actually see the line of lightning.
And here we have...
a big, fuck-off, shiny storm.
And to the north, we have a storm.
And just there, we've got a bolt of lightning.
And I imagine around here, in just a moment,
we're going to have a bolt of lightning.
And I imagine just about there,
To the right.
It's from cloud to cloud.
In a moment, we're going to have a strong north-easterly bolt of lightning.
Right there.
Hang on, we're having a few technical difficulties.
Thank you, Bob.
11pm. With the storm still a way off,
the women bed down for a long night under their makeshift shelter.
I can see the rain on this side.
All lights off.
Nighty night.
Bloody hell, have you farted in my face again?
Sorry, I did.
It's 5.30am and the storm has finally hit the island.
The women are hoping their containers are full of rainwater.
We've just had the most uncomfortable sleep of our lives.
It's just a nightmare.
I just hope we can get some water in as soon.
Can I just share something with you, everybody?
Really bad news, we have no water
because the tide has washed our bottles away.
Nothing.
Fuck.
Oh, fuck.
I feel like I could cry right now.
I seriously think I could cry.
I think I need a little shit.
After almost 48 hours with hardly anything to drink,
the women sourced just a handful of coconuts.
Oh, my God, this one's cold!
Ah!
But with only enough liquid to have a few sips each,
one woman is finding it all too much.
You all right, Kate?
Just struggling.
I'm really struggling, guys.
Come on, come on, come on.
Give some love.
I'm really, really missing my girl.
I've decided to do this because, having been made redundant four times,
it left me feeling worthless and a burden on everybody.
And I wanted to set myself a challenge
and do something that was extremely difficult,
but that I had to do, and that I can't walk away from it.
I have more confidence in myself.
I make my children proud of me.
I make my husband, Chris, proud of me.
I just feel like I've bitten off more than I can chew.
No, not at all.
I'm with God, you are doing brilliant.
You are doing absolutely brilliant,
and they're going to be so proud of you.
I know.
I just want to speak to Chris.
And have him say, keep going.
You can't do everything through your kids and your husband.
You have to have some me time.
But I like doing everything through them.
OK, well, that's cool.
I think initially, when people get marooned,
it's all about the fun.
The physical, the fact that they're tired,
and they're hungry, and they're hurting.
But after a while, people become accustomed to that.
But then the battle becomes something much more meaningful.
Actually, the fact that you're missing your loved ones.
And those battles can be much harder.
I'm so thirsty.
I haven't managed to find any water.
Look at that.
The good news for the women is that in tropical storm season,
the weather can change in an instant.
Guys, guys, bring your pots.
It's running like a bloody tap.
The return of the rain proves to be their salvation.
Yes.
Woo-hoo.
First in the jungle.
Ah.
Watch my mouth, they think.
Oh, my god.
This is amazing.
Wow.
Cheers.
Oh, my god.
That is just the best feeling.
Yeah, baby.
From the most miserable situation to the most joyous situation.
Yeah, see?
We go up, we go down, we go up, we go down.
We were right through the floor down, and now we're elated.
Rehydrated.
Time to dive.
And with bottles full of water.
And we came down this one.
The expedition party set off.
Confident they'll finally rescue the others.
Okay, so we're on the right track.
In the jungle.
The mighty jungle.
The lion sneaks tonight.
Go.
A-wimboing.
It's the women's fifth day on the island.
And the two groups have been separated for over two days.
Spirits are buoyed with bottles full of rain water,
but the expedition party are going round in circles,
trying to return to camp
to rescue the women waiting.
We want to stay in a straight line.
Nobody's disagreeing with you.
We will have to make little diversions.
No, that way.
Mum of two, Kate, remains desperately homesick,
missing her family.
Just doing my head in.
Because I'm not doing another night in this jungle like this.
That will be it for me, and I've made that decision.
If we don't make it back... You feel that strongly about it now?
Yep, and I know the people who matter to me the most
won't care if I come home early, to be honest.
Kate, calm down. We're going the right direction.
It might not be... I'm not talking to you.
..like a path. I'm talking to George.
I know. Fucking attitude and a half, you do.
And you can kiss my fucking arse.
If these women are going to survive, they've got to learn quickly
how to work together as a team.
Pulling together is paramount in times of crisis,
and the truth is we always survive better
when we're together.
When we cooperate and when we don't fight.
Um, there's only... Please, no negativity.
We just need to keep on this positively.
I know you've got a really bad attitude, Kate.
I haven't. I'm just fed up.
You're speaking to everyone with a really bad tone,
so can everybody please stop arguing?
Because it's really not helping.
But maybe we should just, for the next ten minutes,
all of us just say completely nothing
and just concentrate on walking and following Fee.
No, that way.
Guys, I think we need to go that way.
Hold on, hold on, hold on, hold on.
Silence.
I'm asking a few group of women to keep silent.
We lasted literally ten...
Everyone, good idea. Ten seconds.
At camp, the group have spent over two days with no food,
drinking just small amounts of rainwater,
waiting for the expedition party to return.
And damp conditions have brought out the jungle critters.
Like, right now, all my arse is proper itchy.
It's only got a few bites, but above it, my face, my hands...
Shiaz, we've just looked at her arse.
Oh, yeah, we have just looked at her bum.
The rain last night was ridiculous.
Like, I was just...
I'm so ill that I just need to sleep.
Like, my throat, I can't swallow.
I don't know how to do this.
I want to show everyone I can do this, but it's really hard.
Whenever I have a problem, my parents always help me out.
Right now, my dad pays for everything that I want.
My boyfriend looks after me, especially on nights out.
They see me as their baby that they still need to protect.
I don't do anything by myself, and I want to be more independent.
I want to do something for myself
and just be able to be like, yes, I did that.
The worst part is I'm starting to think that my parents were right.
I shouldn't have done this.
Back in the jungle, Forrester's daughter, Fi,
has taken over leadership of the trek back to camp.
But it's only taken half an hour for the mood to disintegrate.
We really strongly think we need to go right here.
I've got to say, I do agree.
Oh, brilliant.
We have been travelling in the past,
we have been travelling in this direction.
No, we haven't.
We've been travelling in that direction.
No.
Yeah.
Why is it you're so adamant you're right all the time?
Just hold on.
I'm not adamant I'm right all the time.
Yes, you are, because you're dismissing everybody else.
Listen, I understand.
Fi will not listen.
Jeez, I live in the woods, so I always circumnavigate woods.
Well done.
But we spent the night last night in a place that we had just left.
You never noticed... That was my fault.
..that we'd double back on us.
That was my fault.
We never noticed we'd double back.
Because she wasn't in charge.
It's often when stress levels are high that all the social graces fall away,
and it's also when tempers fray.
They've got to learn quickly how to communicate better as a team.
At this point, their survival and that of the women at camp depends on it.
We have to spend another night in this jungle like this.
I'm out of here.
You need to listen to people.
You don't listen to anybody.
I do think that you really don't listen to anybody.
And this is actually... Is this life or death?
I'm just so tempted to tell you to take the lead and do it.
Yeah, cos then if I leave, it's my own fault, because I'd have got us lost.
And give up.
OK, I have the machete.
Oh, my God! What?
Help! Becky!
Becky!
I'm coming!
Call the medics!
She's gone!
Bran! Bran's fainted!
Radio in, medic, now!
She's absolutely fucking boiling.
Oh, my God!
With Belinda, the only doctor amongst her 13 women,
lost with the expedition party,
the group at camp must radio for a safety response team to intervene.
Doctor Bravo, do you copy?
We see you missing, girl.
Bran, passed out.
They are on standby on a nearby island in case of emergency.
Erm...
She's boiling. I need to get some air to her.
Oh, my God!
This is way fucking beyond any fucking joke.
Everyone needs off here, I swear to God.
It's not a programme. It's fucking ridiculous.
Having gone to the rocks for air,
after five days with barely any food or water,
Fran has taken a serious turn for the worse.
The safety response team arrive.
Hello, Fran.
We're just dealing with a flat, squirrely cause at that location.
I think the problem is with Fran.
I think she's not a moaner.
I think she's been far iller than we knew.
We're going to put her on a stretcher,
we're going to take her on our boat,
and then we're going to do proper assessment
and see what needs to happen from there.
With the group at camp a member down
and the expedition party lost with dwindling water supplies,
the women's existence on the island hangs in the balance.
Look at that.
We need a radio in, medic, now.
The 13 women have been split apart for two days.
She's collapsed. Oh, my God!
And the group at camp
are now a member down after Fran collapsed
and was evacuated from the island.
Another one gone?
I knew she was poorlier than we thought.
Out at sea, my safety response team
are assessing 24-year-old Fran.
It says 72 and 146.
I don't care how, like, dehydrated or faint I am,
the rest of us are exactly the same.
I shouldn't get any privileged treatment
over feeling a bit sick.
I'm just really pissed off at myself.
I know I can do this.
Till I faint 400 times, you're not allowed to take me off that thing.
After five days without anywhere near enough water,
Fran has succumbed to dehydration.
And with the expedition party still nowhere in sight,
the other four women are equally at risk.
What the hell?
There's so many people dropping off.
I'm just worried there's going to be more and more.
Because people can't stand these conditions.
Fran's coming back. Fran's coming back.
Is she really?
Fran's body temperature and heart rate have returned to normal.
And in Dr Belinda's absence,
the safety response team deem her fit enough to rejoin the others.
Is it like heaven, seeing us?
Oh, I'm sure.
I'm sure there's things she'd rather see than us.
I had to beg her.
I had to beg them to let me back on the island.
I just had to come back, though,
cos, like, then it would be only four girls here
and I couldn't leave them.
I'm so glad I'm back.
The expedition party have been walking for two days,
trying to find their way back to camp.
This is where I feel we should go.
This looks like a pretty good path.
Having wrestled leadership of the group,
homesick mum of two, Kate,
is now guiding the women through the jungle.
This is going to go well.
Just keep going.
This is where you want to go.
The thought of not getting there, stressing me out, you know?
We will get there.
I'm not confident to take responsibility for this.
OK, well, where are we going now?
Where are we going now?
Just keep going straight. No more confrontational arguing.
Just keep walking.
It's just that way. Keep going, keep going, keep going.
Well, I'm losing my confidence now.
I don't want to lead.
I'm sorry, I don't want to lead this group.
I don't want to.
I'll lead it. You tell me where to go.
Or do you know what?
Or you lead. What do you think?
And I'm just saying a word. No, no, no.
No, I'm not going to say another word
because I'm having a complete crisis of confidence in myself.
I'm so scared.
We're all scared.
Because you were so confident.
Yeah, but that's... I know, but...
Now it's gone.
My confidence is gone.
Sorry, I should just keep my mouth shut.
You lead the way, Faye, please.
Fuck!
After over two days of waiting and now dangerously dehydrated,
the women at camp are finally taking their fate into their own hands.
They haven't found us, so we've got no alternative but to find them.
Because we've stayed and we've waited, I don't even know,
two days, three days, to be rescued.
If we don't find them,
I think we're going to make a raft and go to another island.
I just never, ever want to see this spot ever in my life again.
Until now, staying put.
Staying put has actually been the surest way
of allowing the others to try and find them.
But after days with no fire, dwindling water supplies, no food,
the women now need to weigh out the dangers of striking out into the unknown
against the risk of waiting it out with no more resources.
Now we have to just go and blow our whistles madly
to see if anyone's hearing us, and that's what we're going to do.
That's the plan. Blow, blow, blow.
Everybody in this group is good at blowing, yeah?
Yeah?
I think we're all...
We're the reason blowers here.
Yeah, girls?
Yes.
Unaware of the expedition party's whereabouts,
the five women are searching the coastline.
Our journey to find the other team begins now.
Whoa.
Are you all right, sweetheart?
Yeah, sorry.
Cracking on.
Good on you.
Oh, it's so cold.
Oh, my gosh, my knickers are getting wet.
Oh, my God.
At least our fannies will feel fresher.
Yeah.
Having left Coconut Beach three hours ago,
the expedition party are completely lost
and their water supply is fast disappearing.
After homesick mum of two, Kate, quit as leader,
Georgie recognises where they are.
Oh, my God.
I made these, Mark.
I knew I recognised this place.
The women are convinced they are finally about to find camp.
Do you remember you, me and Abi did a recce?
This is where we came to.
I know.
That's what I was just saying.
They're just down there.
I'm ecstatic just because I got the hell out of Shit Creek.
Fuck, that's so fucking deep.
That's up to my tits, so that's swimming for Fran.
It feels desperate because we feel so close right now.
No!
Yeah.
We haven't had a response on the signal.
I'm coming out.
Along the coast,
the group from camp have entered the mangrove swamps.
Are we?
OK. OK.
I can't do this.
I've got you. I've got you.
You can totally do this.
One, two, three.
There we go.
With the sweltering midday sun beating down on us,
the dehydrated women,
55-year-old cashier Julie is struggling.
Oh, fuck.
It's all right, hold me.
Back one's in now.
Left and right, left and right.
There.
That's it.
OK, so feet...
I need to leave me boots.
No, you're going to need to take those with you.
You're going to need them.
So we can do it.
We'll just take our time.
No rush.
Oh, friggin' hell.
Oh, fuck.
Oh, God.
Right?
Yeah, thanks.
Another mark.
Look, another one.
Snap.
Yeah, brilliant.
Yeah, this is it.
This is good.
I recognise this.
We're so damn close, though.
So close.
This does look familiar.
We're literally round this corner.
Is that a pink potty down there?
Yes.
So you recognise it?
We're at Coconut fucking Beach.
No, we're not.
Yeah, we're at Coconut Beach.
We are.
You're right, we are.
What the fuck?
Come on, let's get down there.
I can't fucking deal with this.
The women have circled back to Coconut Beach
for a second time.
Having pushed through the jungle for two days,
they're not one step closer to camp.
How the fuck is that possible?
How is this possible?
We kept the sea to our left the whole time.
After conquering the mangroves,
the group from camp continue north.
Guys, it's a beach!
Woo!
I can't believe we're here.
Becky, this is what I've been dreaming of.
After five days being trapped in the jungle,
they remain determined to find the expedition party.
I thought we were so fucking close,
like, three minutes away.
It's only round the corner, but we can't fucking navigate.
We cannot navigate through that.
I'm stressed because I thought we were so close.
And then I can't walk and I'm just fucked
and we're all fucked.
It sucks.
Three nights without water,
fucking trousers like this.
I can't do it. No way.
I was wanting to see them and see if they were OK.
How the fuck did that happen?
I don't even understand.
We cannot walk anywhere on this island
and we're getting lost.
It's a maze.
It's the world's trickiest maze.
Shall we have a 30-second shade break?
No.
I need to go and see.
OK.
Another beach, but not as nice as the one we're on.
Hang on.
Is that a load of clothes hanging in that tree?
Hello!
What? I can hear someone.
I'll be back to pick you up.
This is the 35thвер fact of all the
Yeah.
I think I've got to pick it up.
Oh!
Woo!
How ever bad your situation is, you can't wallow in negativity, you know, survival is
about dogged determination, learning from your failures and never giving up.
Finally, back together, the women take a moment to savour their island home.
We needed them, we've all got different strengths and weaknesses that help, it's just kind of
complete.
By evening, with the reunited group, 13 women strong, it's all hands on deck to light a
new fire.
But after being lost for two days, island survival has taken its toll on mum of two,
Kate.
It's just a dream.
It's just the whole end.
The blunt end.
If I'm really honest with you, I can't see it getting any better.
I feel really tired and very, very emotional.
To try and be a part of this group, but they're not the people I need to be with.
I need to be with my family.
And I just need to be at home.
The general feeling is, I'm not going to be home.
I'm going to be home.
Take me home, please.
By morning, furniture maker Kate has made her decision.
I'm not going home because I'm dehydrated.
I'm not going home because I can't pack it.
I'm going home because I want to be at home.
You contribute so much.
You really do.
But it's been difficult for me because I've been missing people so much.
That won't be possible with any help.
You've been missing people so much. That won't get any easier.
That'll get worse.
Oh, my God, it's horrible seeing another one go.
I thought she'd hang on in there.
We need everybody, and she had good knowledge
of bloody building and stuff.
Mum was fucking pissed off.
I just think it's weak of her to do that.
She's giving up too easily.
We need each other to boost each other up.
But it's the old thing, isn't it?
Kids, mum and her kids.
It's the old pull.
Men can do it, but a lot of women can't.
After barely a week on the island,
a second member of the team has quit.
And with power in numbers,
the women's ability to survive is diminishing.
I'm a bit pissed off.
I think it's a great shame,
because the hit was a great one.
It was a fantastic experiment to see how 14 women could cope
in this situation.
And two of them have gone already,
and I don't think that shows us all in particularly good light.
Next time on the island...
Sometimes out here can feel like you've been hit
by a major disaster.
So thin now.
All sorts of bones appearing
that I haven't seen since I was a bloody teenager.
We need to find a solid source of food
or we could be facing meltdown.
Every fucker's bitching and moaning
that you're doing fuck all when it comes to water.
I'd say we're 95% sure we've got a caiman in our second trap.
Holy fuck.
Come on, baby.
Sam, get out of the water, mate.
Watch him, watch him. Go now, go now.
Captions by Red Bee Media
Copyright Australian Broadcasting Corporation